milyen volt ott
lenni neked az elején amikor még csak
egy egy két hetes periódusra mentél
meglátogatni
izraelt igazából úgy éreztem hogy
hazajöttem az első alkalom tehát egy
ilyen visszatérés a gyökerekhez egy
ilyen ilyen érzésemhoz és nagyon érdekes
volt
hogy hogy úgy is fogadtak minthogyha
hazajöttem volna
tehát minden olyan természetes volt az
emberek közvetlenek voltak tehát hogy
nagyon nagyon könnyen alakítottam ki
kapcsolat okat ezt megfigyeltem tehát
hogy leültem bárkivel beszélgetni már
olyan mély témákra mentünk hogy azt
hiszem hogy az európai kultúrával el
kell tölteni pár pár hetet valakivel
hogy olyan dolgokra rákérdezzem milyen
nyelven beszéltetek gondolom angolul az
elején nyilván nem tudtam héberül az
elején nem tudtam héberül tehát angolul
beszélt mindegy aránylag mindenki jól
beszél angolul tehát még a gyerekek is a
gyerekek is egész jól beszélnek angolul
meg izraelnek egy része ugye itt a
környező állam ból is származik meg egy
része európából jött a zsidóságnak haza
szóval szóval így a az angol nyelv az
nem egy nem egy probléma ha valaki nem
tudja értenni angolul akkor tud oroszul
általáni ez a felállás